alright guys it's time for ten more
things you didn't know about Dark Souls
just like last time let's play the game
if I tell you something new in this
video you leave a like if you somehow
knew everything in this video you can
leave a dislike guilt free ready let's
go number one did you know that the
Hydra in ash lake performs a jumping
attack if you go past a certain point
wait too easy for you you already knew
that
fine let's make it harder number two the
first time you encounter sea you can
actually go back through the folk gate
to postpone that mandatory death number
three if you look closely you can see
the NPCs captured within the big head
crystals of the golden crystal columns
look closely here and you'll see dusk
look closely on this one and you'll see
Sieglinde number four you can offer
range support and distract the gaping
dragon while the host fights it just
don't enter the fog gate number five on
stains finger twitches just before he
gets smashed he's alive snow just
doesn't give a [ __ ] number six you can
see manases eyes before you enter the
room you can even kill him with the bow
from here if you have an hour to spare
number seven did you know you can see
your soul slime from any two points in
the world this is the longest distance I
could find but there's some other great
examples out there number eight is
something easily overlooked there are
three different poses when you're
sitting at the bonfire
number nine isn't necessarily a fact
it's more of a very likely theory at the
very least you have to admit that it's
logical Oskar drops you the key to
yourself from the roof while he's alive
and well however the asylum demon is
also on the roof when you next encounter
Oskar he's in a room with no obvious
entrance except for this one hole in the
roof he's fatally wounded with rubble
all around him put two and two together
and you realize that it's likely he was
fighting the asylum demon on the roof
until he was smashed into this room and
last but definitely not least number ten
just in case there's that one guy here
who still knows everything this should
get you did you know that if you use a
fire weapon to kill the bloated hollows
then you won't get poison
well that's ten more things you didn't
know about Dark Souls and if you knew
everything on that list then you're
doing pretty damn well if you want to
try again and you haven't seen part one
then check that out here now if you feel
like you could do with some more Dark
Souls content then stick around I'm
going to give you some good connections
first up his Hellkite Drake this guy is
relatively unknown but he definitely
doesn't deserve to be held kite makes
amazing remixes of the Dark Souls
soundtrack and his work will be featured
in future prepare to cry videos he
already provided the violence Ryan remix
for my heroes of violent shrine video if
you want to experience his work before
it finds its way onto my channel go
subscribe the second guy you should
follow has created the thumbnail art for
most of my videos and he's responsible
for that distinctive look they have on
YouTube I say you should follow him
because his content can be found on
tumblr so if you have a tumblr then
click this link and go check out Carson
drew a tumblr comm so these two guys
have helped me out a lot in return for a
little exposure if you feel like you
have a talent that you'd like to feature
on this channel whether it's music
animation artwork or otherwise then get
in contact I believe everyone has a
talent for something and I'd love to
support others and encourage them to get
their talent out there I might be good
at creative writing and making these
videos but in reality there's probably a
thousand other things that you can do
better than me and I'd love to see what
your talent is send me a message through
Twitter or inbox the last guy I'm giving
a shout-out to today is a user named Rua
Khan you probably already know he has
some of the best souls playthroughs on
YouTube and you do well to check him out
so as a final link is his in-depth
analysis of the Dark Souls 2 gameplay
reveal so hey thanks for sticking around
for the shoutouts and I'll catch you
guys next time
you